every day science pushes further on
beyond our yesterday's limits in space
exploration
and it may look like the great minds of
the scientific community would by now
have conducted exhaustive studies of
objects like satellites and planets
nearest to us
however the space accommodating our
solar system is truly enormous
and it will take us a lot of time to be
able to claim it to have been
investigated completely
now i invite you on a journey to our
solar system's remotest parts
to its very edge and see what was the
last thing
seen by the new horizons spacecraft on
sharon
pluto's mysterious moon
the first in outer space
sharon is pluto's largest moon by now it
has been known to science for over 40
years
this celestial object was spotted on the
22nd of june 1978 by the american
astronomer james christie
it was first seen in images provided by
the united states naval observatory
flagstaff station
at first sharon was defined as pluto's
only moon
however according to another opinion
which spread around later
these two celestial objects had to be
considered as a binary system
if sharon were to be given the dwarf
planet status this would effectively be
the definitive point in establishing the
object's nature and classifying it
as it is there is no unambiguous
definition for these objects in space
and sharron is still classified as
pluto's moon
sharon's diameter measures 1212
kilometers
this is about twice as little as the
diameter of pluto
and about three times as little as that
of our moon
it takes sharon 6.387 earth days to
orbit pluto
interestingly the rotation period of
both objects
equals the same time span on account of
mutual tidal locking of the
two i will remind you that this means
that the celestial objects face each
other with one on the same side at all
times
bizarre as it may seem if we were to
find ourselves on the surface of either
of the two objects
then sharon in pluto's sky or else pluto
in sharon's sky
would stay in the same position without
shifting
for this exciting property the two are
often called a double planet
and sometimes a double dwarf planet
actually it's worth mentioning that the
barycenter of the system does not lie
within either of the two objects
speaking about their mass ratio sharon's
is approximately 11.65 percent
that of pluto and as for the distance
between the objects
they lie 19 570 kilometers away from
each other
just to compare the average distance
between the earth and the moon
may reach up to 384
400 kilometers another exciting feature
of this system was noticed in the period
from february 1985 to october 1990
when an extremely rare phenomenon was
registered by scientists on many
occasions
namely alternate eclipses of pluto by
sharon and vice versa
since sharon's orbital period lasts for
less than a week
eclipses were observed to occur about
every three days
if we compare the two objects looks
charon is noticeably darker than pluto
due to its properties
besides the two differ very much in
their chemical composition
for example there is a lot of nitrogen
ice on pluto's surface
whereas cheren is covered with water ice
which doesn't make it look quite so
reddish
today the pluto sharing system is
believed to have formed as a result of a
collision of pluto and proto-sharon
with the two having been formed
independently prior to the collision
according to some suggested models
sharon may be geologically active
and contain liquid under its surface
this assumption is based on the fact
that there are ammonia hydrates detected
by spectral analysis of the object
there are also hypotheses suggesting
that there is cryovolcanism to be
registered on sharing
most information about this celestial
object was collected thanks to the new
horizons mission when the interplanetary
spacecraft
passed through the pluto sharing system
on the 14th of july 2015.
in the course of the mission images of
sharon were obtained from various
distances
with the smallest distance to the object
during the flyby about
28 800 kilometers
the spacecraft was able to take
snapshots of sharon's side
seat on closest approach and the
opposite one too
a great number of various features were
identified on this moon's surface
one of them was a fascinating mountain
in the middle of a moat
and a few craters whose pictures were
taken by new horizons from a distance of
000 kilometers in addition to that the
photos reveal the surface to boast
diverse terrain for example there are
photos showing mountain ranges and
troughs
stretching for a thousand kilometers
they must have come to be under the
influence of some internal processes on
sharon
in the top right hand corner there can
be seen a huge canyon
whose depth may reach anything from
seven to nine kilometers
surprisingly there are scarcely any
craters on sharon
which may only mean that this moon's
surface is geologically quite young
another feature on sharon is a layer of
dark dust its north pole is covered with
this bizarre region was dubbed mordor
with its diameter measuring
approximately 475 kilometers
this dark area is believed to have
formed due to dramatic temperature drops
that regularly occur
on sharon's surface one of the reasons
could be sharon's polar winter
which persists for about a hundred years
throughout this period
the surface temperature of the moon
drops to 258 degrees celsius below
zero with molecules of methane and
nitrogen captured from pluto's
atmosphere freezing
when summer is back and the north pole's
temperature
rises as high as 213 degrees celsius
below zero
methane and nitrogen evaporate and only
heavy compounds are left in the mordor
region
on exposure to ultraviolet radiation
they turn into thalines
this may actually be the reason why this
area is of this dark hue
[Music]
today all the objects on sharon's
surface have been informally nicknamed
after science fiction and fantasy
writers
and their books among the geological
features you can find clark montes and
kubrick montes
craters kirk uhura vader
skywalker ripley nostromo
tardis cosma gallifrey macular and
vulcan planum to name but a few
apart from sharon pluto has four more
moons we know of
their names are stixx nyx kerberos and
hydra
and their raw bits are almost circular
following the direction of pluto's
rotation
while pluto and sharon rotate
synchronously
the other objects have been noticed not
to do so
as usual here is a brief profile of each
nix's orbits radius measures up to 49
000 kilometers while hydra's orbits
radius
is 65 000 kilometers this makes them two
to three times
further from pluto than sharon is
hydra measures 43 by 33 kilometers
nix's parameters are 54 by 41 by 36
kilometers
their masses still haven't been
estimated yet but either of the object's
mass
is roughly gauged at .003 percent
that of sharon the other two moons were
discovered in june 2011 and july 2012.
the size of one of them kerberos is 12
by four and a half kilometers
with its orbits radius 58 000 kilometers
sticks measures seven by five kilometers
and its orbits radius is 42 000
kilometers
in spite of their modest dimensions the
new horizons spacecraft did manage to
take a few snapshots of them too
having passed through the pluto sharing
system and having collected data about
all of pluto's moons the space probe
traveled on
and the last images of these objects
beamed back to the earth were the
clearest of the day
[Music]
on the 14th of july 2015 the spacecraft
took one of the last
and better quality photos of sharon from
a distance of 74
176 kilometers in this picture
many geological features of this object
are very clearly seen
today sharon admittedly remains a
celestial object
far from being thoroughly explored
however thanks to the data gathered in
the course of the accomplished missions
were able to make well-grounded
assumptions about its nature
properties and evolution while the new
horizons mission heralded a
revolutionary breakthrough
a number of similar projects are likely
to be launched in the nearest decades
which means that very soon we will
probably find out more about this
exciting space object
and if you'd like to find out more about
other objects in the solar system
feel free to specify in the comments and
i will do my best to tell you about them
in later videos
also feel free to hit the like button
under this video
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you